c'est en compagnie de son vice président
le colonel assimi goïta le chef de la
junte que le nouveau président de la
transition banda au a été investi ce
vendredi au moment de la ville de zhouqu
qui doit être là sommes en démocratie
je combattais sans concession de scooter
au cou par tour
un combat affiché contre la corruption
dans un discours qui marque le lancement
d'une période de transition majeure
peu connu du grand public l'ancien
officier de l'armée de l'air formé dans
l'ex urss a connu une brillante carrière
au sein des forces armées maliennes
pilote d'hélicoptère aide de camp du
président moussa traoré chef d'état
major de l'armée de l'air
il a également été ministre de la
défense où ibrahim boubacar keïta entre
2014 et 2015
un nouveau président qui fait figure
d'homme intègre pour la junte et
notamment à 6 me go et à son vice
président les deux hommes chemineront
ensemble pour une période de 18 mois
avant de remettre les clés à un
gouvernement civil après des élections
démocratiques et transparentes
chose encore en compte mais les as
possible
de son côté la cedeao félicite le
nouveau gouvernement pour cette étape
importante franchie mais souligne
l'importance de l'application de la
justice et le respect de la charte de
transition dont la version finale n'a
pas encore été transmise la mission
insiste sur la libération urgente de ces
personnalités
conformément aux décisions les chefs
d'état et de vous
la cedr la mission a pris acte de la
nomination et de l'investiture de
monsieur banda en qualité de président
de la transition elle le félicite
chaleureusement et du souhaite plein
succès dans la conduite de sa mission
concernant les sanctions à accra le
président de l'autorité de la cedeao
sous le commandement du président du
ghana a clairement indiqué
qu'immédiatement après la nomination
d'un premier ministre civil les
sanctions seront levés un nouveau départ
sous étroite surveillance
avec de lourdes sanctions de la part de
la communauté économique des états de
l'afrique de l'ouest
prochaine étape donc très attendu le
choix du premier ministre qui devrait
avoir lieu dans quelques jours pour
permettre enfin la levée des sanctions
contre le pays